we've just have some breaking news
that's just coming into us which is that
prince andrew has reached a financial
settlement with virginia du frey and
this is what court documents have just
revealed this is a report that we're
just hearing coming in for us now let's
go straight to rihanna mills who's our
royal correspondent who can give us more
details on that rhiannon well these
documents have literally just been filed
on the court system in the last few
moments um i will read to you what the
letter says which has been written
to the judge lewis kaplan by david boyes
who is virginia duprey's lawyer and in
essence sets out that a settlement has
been reached between virginity frey and
prince andrew so the letter says
virginia dufrey and prince andrew have
reached an out of court settlement
it goes on to say the parties will file
a stipulated dismissal upon mr frey's
receipt of the settlement the sum of
which is not being disclosed prince
andrew intends to make a substantial
donation to mr phrase charity in support
of victims rights it then goes on to say
that prince andrew has never intended to
malign mr frey's character and he
accepts that she has suffered
both as an established victim of abuse
and as a result of unfair public attacks
it's known that jeffrey epstein
trafficked countless young girls over
many years prince andrew regrets his
association with epstein and commends
the bravery of mr frey and other
survivors in standing up themselves and
others he pledges to demonstrate his
regret for his association with epstein
by supporting the fight against the
evils of sex trafficking and by
supporting its victims
now it has to be said that this
settlement has come out of the blue in
recent weeks and months we have simply
seen ongoing brinkmanship between the
two sides between virginia
dufrese lawyers and also prince andrews
legal team and certainly in recent weeks
it did appear that this case was heading
to trial and we know that the judge had
already put that potential trial date in
the diary that was potentially going to
happen between september and december
this year but now as we're hearing a
settlement has been reached
i think it is worth reminding ourselves
exactly what this case is about and it
has rumbled on for so many years the
first time i remember reporting on it
was all the way back in 2015 and it's
revolved around the fact that virginia
dufrese has
claimed over the years that on three
separate occasions she was sexually
assaulted by the duke of york these are
claims that he has always vehemently
denied but virginia dufrese has insisted
that they did happen
and that they happened as a result of
jeffrey epstein trafficking her as she
says he did to a number of different
individuals but prince andrew right from
2015 has consistently denied these
allegations
against him this was always something
that's continued to hang over him and
the royal family for so many years now
and yet we're hearing in this latest
court document that virginia dufrey and
prince andrew have now reached an
out-of-court settlement
has this come as a surprise though
because of course what we understood was
that prince andrew was going to give
evidence under oath and so this news
then has that come as a surprise at all
it certainly has come as a surprise
because of the considerable brinkmanship
that we've seen
between the two sides certainly ever
since the hearings began
it was back in the summer last year that
virginia du frey filed this civil case
against prince andrew and then the the
court hearings really started around
december and have continued into
into january and and february this year
and in those documents that we've seen
filed online and through those court
hearings consistently prince andrew and
his legal team have in essence said
that virginia due phrase claims are
false and without foundation they also
of course try to put forward this
argument that actually she was not able
to sue other individuals because she'd
already done that with jeffrey epstein
back in
2009 and the settlement that was reached
with jeffrey epstein actually meant that
she was unable to take legal action
against any other individuals so they
were fighting very hard from prince
andrew's team
to try and get this case thrown out but
of course the judge said virginia defray
is able to proceed with this case and
that's why we've been hearing over
recent weeks about the fact that prince
andrew was set to to give a deposition
so give his own witness statement on the
10th of march that was literally only
only weeks away and also how virginia
dufrey was also going to tell her side
story also they were naming other
individuals that they wanted to call as
witnesses
but now i think it is worth for those
who are just hearing this story now uh
it's worth reiterating that an out of
court settlement has now been reached
between
virginia dufrese the woman who claims
that when she was just 17 years old she
was sexually assaulted by prince andrew
on three separate occasions claims that
he has always denied
also the letter that's been submitted to
the judge says that uh the sum that's
kind of past this settlement is not
going to be disclosed but it also goes
on to say that prince andrew intends to
make a substantial donation to ms
dufrey's charity in support of victims
rights also interestingly it says prince
andrew regrets his association
with epstein and if you remember all the
way back to that news night interview in
2019 that was one thing that he didn't
say
he did not say that he regretted that
friendship he talked about how important
that relationship had been when it came
to his business work but i think many
people were shocked at the time to hear
that he wouldn't say he regretted uh his
relationship his association with a
convicted
sex offender so in this letter i'm
saying that prince andrew regrets his
association with epstein and also that
he pledges to demonstrate his regret for
his association
with epstein by now supporting the fight
against the evils of sex trafficking